okay so hicaro needs to win
he starts with more time he starts with
five minutes magnus willingly chose
black
with four minutes the issue is
with no increment there's more
possibilities for dirty flag
which was not the case in the previous
games all the previous games had
increments
so that's very bold by magnus to
[Music]
to pick the side with less time
i'm i'm really curious that they get to
a situation let's say
let's say something like king and rook
versus king and rook
where hikaru has more time does he go
for the dirty flag
this is going to be intense
yeah i feel like there's high there's
very high tension
alexa who's going to win magnus or
hikaru
sorry i'm not sure i'm not sure either
that's why i was asking you and the next
game
it could just be the most important game
of the year
i i know i've said this throughout the
match like this match is just the most
important match of the the year
but um it all comes down to this game
armageddon
alexa quiet oh that was really good
timing
alexa like knew exactly when the game
would start so we have e4
so no english are we gonna see a bomb
cloud
no oh he he mouse slipped knight f3 yet
again
okay up
alexa made like a passive aggressive
sound
i assume there's some delay with the
move transmission
um yeah the moves are coming in so
they're repeating a spanish
magnus really has to watch his time
um yeah both sides blitzing out the
so this is the same opening scene
earlier but not quite
moves are coming in really really
quickly
i was going to say who's going to be the
first one to think
but looks like maybe it was a karu
the moves are still coming in they're
out of theory
they're out of mastery database theory
out of chess database theory
um and we see we see magnus castle
queenside this is
not what we saw earlier uh oh hicaro
also castling queenside
it's it's very rare you see an opening
where both players
castle queen side
so this could be more positional just
because the kings are on the same side
and what hicario wants he just wants a
very long game where he can
he can really chip away at magnus's time
he's still up a minute
maybe up a little bit more than a minute
and her car was so good at like having
like being able to play long games where
he just kind of
maneuvers around dances around
so yeah this is armageddon a draw for
magnus is equivalent to a win
um but hikaru's white hikaru has more
time
knight h4 my h4
i don't know what the point is it
prevents rookie one cause knight g2
maybe the idea idea could be g6 kick the
knight away and then knight g2 knight f4
and get some kind of outpost
um oh so g5
so just securing control over over f4
moves still coming in very quickly rook
g1 was preventing knight g2 but
light found its way to f4 knights get
traded
and now it's um it's still a pretty
closed position
wait what just happened slow motion
replay h5
so the first trade of pawns we now have
one open file
which black controls oh magnus is
controlling very nicely
but it looks like recaro is trying to
open the g file
this actually reminds me of like a
reverse variation of a queen's gambit
wow c4 c4 is so explosive
so basically trading pawns but getting
the queen to a3
white's still solid though
like the bishop the bishop is on a
pretty square but it's restricted by
white's pawns
oh do i turn on sockfish there's a lot
of sesay evaluations in the chat i can
have sockfish
yeah i mean i think it's it's still
close to equal here
it's it's going to come down to time
or maybe it's going to come down to
magnus's mating attack
i'm going to push that a pawn
so this e pawn it looks weak but white
can't really take it
because the rooks are the rook is tied
down to other rook
and white can't take here because of the
back rank issues
so the rooks are kind of at a standstill
i like knight b5 just chase the queen
away
rook c7 also looks nice aligning with
the king
okay so trade of rooks occur now the
rook would like to return but then you
have to
watch out for rook h1
magnus still down on time but it's
getting closer
and the position has simplified a lot
and it's very um
it seems a bit more static now so knight
a4 may be going for c5
also just blockading this pawn
so yeah we could see bishop d7 some
repetition
madness goes for the queen trade that's
probably a very good decision
if queens come off it's much easier to
play
and this could this could really come
down to a dirty time scramble
and there's so much money on the line
i like queen c3 okay keeping tension and
maybe preparing this maneuver
um because e5 can never be defended
by the bishop and the light's just gonna
sit very happily
on d3 so rook h3 a nice counter attack
so now knight d3 walks into this
so rook f1 makes a lot of sense to over
defend the f pawn and then prepare
knight d3
rook d1 also playable the knight
defended the rook
whoa okay so hikaru going for trades
oh rook takes d3 wow so
wow okay so they just had a
large tactical sequence basically a fair
trade
hikaru won the queen but
now it's kind of a race between the
pawns
and okay stalker's still getting
slightly better for whites
yeah magnus lost the queen but kind of
willingly willingly lost a queen
oh this is so crazy like both sides are
so close to promoting
but they're both kind of stuck and the
queen is always targeting the pawn
so they're just trading pawns wow
again it's gonna come down to time and
and karo is
i think i think he's just faster in
these situations
i mean they both play a lot of bullet
chess
objectively this should just be a draw
like black just has a fortress
but there's no way a car was just
peacefully accepting repetition
but oh pawns are getting traded
man yeah this this is like an easy easy
draw
so this is the situation i was thinking
of like before the game
is what happens when it's like easy draw
but now it just comes down to who can
move quicker
oh man
so magnus just wants to try and repeat
and he has enough time yeah it's easy
like just move the rook back and forth i
think magnus is going to win
hakuro not moving realizing that
it's so easy for black
uh oh what's happening
game over is it game over
did magnus magnus won by drawing
we're still waiting for a result
oh it's a draw did they repeat they may
have repeated
or they just agreed to a draw wow
respect to hikaru for not even trying to
go for dirty flag
because that's that's like the logical
thing to do wow magnus one
good job to magnus so many crazy games
um that was a clutch save too
we need a slow motion replay look at
this moment
look at this so it all started with
knight e3
allowing this leetsku magnus
oh yeah tiger's happy otagi was rooting
for magnus
yeah that was a great um i mean this
whole match
like it is kind of unfortunate it came
down to like one armageddon game
but it goes to show that these and
they're they're like very close
in ability especially in in rapid and
blitz
so rook takes f3 white took
here with the idea that if takes takes
white forks
so magnus went for this removing the
guard of the queen
giving away his own queen um
but then winning the rook with check
so that's how the position kind of
got to this situation both sides have
the pass pawn
and then magnus held on with the
fortress
wow oh dead man asking before the
tactical sequence was there a night
check on c5
oh i check on c5 that's a fair point
did dead man find a move that everyone
missed
so knight c5 is playable so the point
that's a very good question
the point is that black is still
completely fine here
because this pawn is a weakness the
bishop will plant itself here
and it's hard to do much with extra
exchange there's also a4 ideas
so um even though technically white spot
material
i guess acaro recover probably saw this
but decided
the other line went or offered a bit
more chances
fortresses do not exist except magnus is
building them p
yeah magnus is really really good
builder
if he wasn't professional chess player
he could be an architect
or a construction worker
well what a game what a match
so i'll probably probably what i'll do
is post this
armageddon commentary on youtube so if
you're watching in the future on youtube
this is like the final
the final game of the match this is what
it all came down to
i encourage people watching if you
haven't
checked out the previous games and
there's
so many channels on twitch on youtube
that have been covering this match chess
24 official broadcast
hikaru's channel with ana rudolph and
levy rosman
i think they had arientari too and they
had mia
about a week ago as well um i know again
matra has been covering almost every
game from this match
so um there's definitely a lot of chess
to reflect on
thank you big evo for the bits
but yeah for people watching in the
future on youtube hope you enjoyed this
subscribe follow on twitch and i'll see
you
in the future and say hi to tagi too
magnus magnus magnus magnus magnus